Speaker 1: Let's get right into things today
because we have so much to discuss.
I'm not going to waste 10 minutes with a meta
segment telling you what's going to be on
today's show.
I mean, this is the show.
Let's just do the show.
Right?
That's my perspective.
I told you yesterday that today we would talk
about a sort of new it's almost like an anti
consensus.
The increasingly the consensus from scientists
about covid and the trajectory of this pandemic
is the end is uncertain.
We don't actually know.
And you'll still hear some individual public
health experts and epidemiologists and others
say if we do, X will probably be mostly back
to normal by some date.
But at this point, it should be pretty clear
to most of us that it's not clear when this
is going to end and that the ifs that are
often referred to, if we get to this level
of vaccination, if there is no more contagious
or dangerous variant, if this these are ifs
over, which we really have very little information
and it's a significantly unclear.
So I want to start here with an article that
outlines this for scientists path to covid
end game remains uncertain.
This is by Marc Fisher from The Washington
Post from this weekend.
It's basically over already.
It will end this October or maybe it won't
be over till next spring or late next year
or two or three years.
Down the road from the most respected epidemiologists
to public health experts who have navigated
past disease panics from polemicists to political
partizans or partizans.
As some like to say, there are no definitive
answers to the central question in American
life.
As a Drudge Report headline put it recently,
is it ever going to end with children returning
to classrooms in many cases for the first
time in 18 months?
And is the highly contagious Delta variant
and spotty vaccination uptake send case numbers
and deaths shooting upward?
Many Americans wonder what exactly has to
happen before life can return to something
that looks and feels like 2019.
The article rightly pointing out the answers,
come in a kaleidoscopic cavalcade of scenarios.
Some suggested with utmost humility, others
with mathematical confidence.
The pandemic will end because deaths finally
drop to about the same level we're accustomed
to seeing from the flu each year.
Or it will end when most kids are vaccinated,
or it will end because Americans are finally
exhausted by all the restrictions on daily
life.
Innumerable predictions over the course of
the pandemic have come up lame.
Some scientists have sworn off soothsaying.
But as they learn more about the coronavirus
that bestand or bestowed covid-19 on mankind,
they build models and make projections and
describe the hurdles that remain before people
can pull their masks, pull off the masks and
go about their lives.
The good news is there is some fuel for optimism.
And I think that I think that this is accurate
in terms of the possibilities of optimism.
Let's look at what it says.
I truly, truly think we are in the end game,
says Monica Gandi, an infectious disease specialist.
The cases will start plummeting in mid to
late September, and by mid-October we will
be in a manageable place where the virus is
a concern for health professionals, but not
really for the general public.
That is very optimistic.
But we are seeing if you expect cases to be
much lower in October.
The leveling off we've seen over the last
seven days suggests that that's a possibility.
Gandi basis her optimism on the fact that
all previous epidemics of respiratory viruses
have ended through the acquisition of immunity,
whether vaccination or natural infection.
Although viruses do keep changing, potentially
circumventing people's defenses, they mutate
quickly at a cost to themselves, weakening
over time.
Our guest, Vincent Racaniello, last week from
the This Week in Virology podcast said the
same in terms of the mutating to be less serious.
Ghandi said she believes the Delta variant
that has hit the US so hard this summer will
mark the peak of the virus is strength.
But Gandhi warns she has been wrong before.
And Feb. 20, she said the US would not tolerate
a disease that killed 100 Americans a day.
People would come together and do whatever
it takes to stop that.
That didn't happen.
The bad news is there is too much cause for
doubt.
Zeke Emanuel, professor of medical ethics
at UT Penn.
We're in a moment of uncertainty.
And humans don't do well with uncertainty.
Telling people it's going to be two or three
more years of this is really hard.
But I don't think anyone can be comfortable
with the current state, with a lot of kids
ending up in the hospital and a thousand deaths
a day, that's not returning to normal.
And Emanuel also says his crystal ball has
sometimes been cloudy in March of 20.
He said the country would be back to normal
in November of twenty one.
For that, his friends dubbed him Mr. Pessimist.
Now his message is at least as unwelcome.
It's going to be at least.
Twenty two and possibly much longer before
things go back to normal.
So at this point, this is as much a psychological
question of what does it do to society to
be living with this for we don't know how
much longer.
Now that psychological pressure has pushed
some who never took it super seriously to
just say we're back to normal.
Either I'm vaccinated and we're back to normal
or I'm not vaccinated.
And I never thought we needed vaccines or
to do anything.
And I'm going to continue in that way.
But when you look at the case and death numbers
tomorrow, I'm going to actually show you cases
are three times higher than a year ago.
Deaths are two times higher than a year ago.
That doesn't feel like it's almost over.
But at the same time, you've got some points
of optimism.
There are some studies that show that an overwhelming
majority, 80 even more percent of some populations
in some cities have some degree of antibodies,
which would be due to a combination of infection,
vaccination, people who never knew they had
it, asymptomatic cases, et cetera.
So what is the point of this?
Do we really know anything?
No.
Yes, maybe.
I don't know.
We do know some things.
We know that this mutates slowly enough that
when you start getting to these higher levels
of immunity, you may not do away with cases,
but cases won't mean nearly as much because
it will mostly mean colds.
And for the vaccinated population, that's
sort of already the case.
I mean, when you read 1500 vaccinated people
have died, it's hard to feel like that means
if you're vaccinated, this no longer matters.
But in the grand scheme of the numbers, that's
a quite small number.
People die of the flu even when vaccinated,
et cetera.
So the last part of this is how do we define
the end?
Are we comfortable saying the end is when
the death numbers are the same as a normal
flu season?
Is that the end?
Has this so traumatized us that even that
won't really signify the end?
Will it be where anyone of any age who wants
to get vaccinated can be vaccinated, which
could be some time until young kids can get
vaccinated?
That's another piece of this, which is how
do we define the end?
The next thing I want to talk about is this
new variant, Ammu, which many of you have
been emailing me about yesterday